[Music]
robert spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the david horowitz freedom
center
and for the center for security policy
if young muslims in western countries
who get involved in juvenile crimes
stop what they're doing and become
observant in islam
authorities should breathe a sigh of
relief right that's what australian
authorities did recently
but things didn't work out quite the way
they had hoped
a young muslim named rabban aloo
according to the daily mail australia
had been in trouble with the law as a
teenager for drug use robbery and armed
robbery
but then he turned to his religion and
australian officials were pleased
the daily mail said a january 2015
report by the department of juvenile
justice
praised alou for getting more involved
in his religion
stopping his cannabis use and
dissociating himself from his negative
peer group
however rabban aloo wasn't really
reforming he was just channeling his
criminality
in a different direction one that the
department of juvenile justice had not
anticipated
in october 2015 less than a year after
that department had happily noted
that he had become a more observant
muslim rabbana liu
helped 15-year-old farhad jabar shoot
police accountant mr
chang outside the new south wales police
headquarters
in parramatta this wasn't just some
random shooting neither
alou supported the islamic state and
frequently prays to the group's violent
jihad activities
in a whatsapp group of australian
soldiers he wrote
omg may allah curse them all and destroy
them to pieces
he rejoiced in the islamic state's
bloodlust writing beheading in france
25 dead and suicide bomb by is in
shia kuwait mosque in 37 dead at tunisia
beach
it's going off lol after viewing footage
of the shooting of
chiang aloo praised jabbar saying ah
brother you're a soldier
oh my god allahu akbar that's beautiful
footage bro
that's beautiful footage you actually
see it all happen you see where he is
last
standing that's where he drops
nonetheless
a lose turn to jihad murder is unlikely
to stop the department of juvenile
justice
from assuming that islam is an unalloyed
force for good
in the next young juvenile offenders
life not just
australia's department of juvenile
justice does this but authorities all
over the west
universally assume this if rabon halu
had been elu had been
anywhere in europe or north america
officials would likely have figured
that his growing more observant in islam
would mean that he would become a good
solid citizen
these officials consistently ignore the
fact that jihadis are virtually all
deeply observant muslims
there has been a good deal of
misinformation about this with islamic
apologists claiming that they're
actually ignorant of islam
or non-observant but there's little if
any evidence to back this claim
a few years ago some islamic state
jihadis ordered some basic books about
islam from amazon
and that is just about the sole evidence
that is ever reduced
to show that jihadis are not
knowledgeable and devout muslims
on the other side is a mountain of
evidence that the islamic state mandated
hours of quran study every day
and the numerous jihadis became more
observant in islam
before they turned to jihad violence the
islamic state that rabban aloo supported
provides numerous examples
in its heyday and down to the present
day as well whenever it issues new
threats to non-muslims
it quotes the quran frequently in
threats to blow up the white house
conquer rome conquer spain in explaining
its priorities
in the nations it is targeting in jihad
in preaching to christians after
collecting
the jizya is which is a quran based tax
as mandated in chapter nine of the quran
in justifying the execution of accused
spies
and in its various videos all of them
are full of quotations of from the koran
the islamic state also awarded ten
thousand dollar prizes and sex slaves
in quran memorization contests one of
its underground layers was found
littered with weapons
and copies of the quran children in the
islamic state studied the quran
and got weapons training one malaysian
muslim
said that the quran led him to join the
islamic state a muslim in the united
states
prompted the islamics promoted the
islamic state by quoting the quran
when islamic state propagandists parents
said of him
our son is a devout muslim he had
learned the quran by heart
a muslim politician from jordan said
that the islamic state's doctrine stems
from the quran and sunnah
despite all this evidence the willful
ignorance among non-muslim authorities
is nearly total
and so when the next wayward muslim
youth comes before them
it is virtually certain that australia's
department of juvenile justice
will demonstrate that it has learned
nothing from the case of rabonalu
and will once again praise the young
man's newfound interest in his faith
it seems as if no matter how destructive
the consequences of this refusal to face
reality become
the fog of false assumptions will not be
dispelled
i'm robert spencer
you